now on a political scene uh one of the
democratic candidates is senator joseph
biden have you seen the problem he's
been having
he went around and made a speech
and apparently
he quoted a i think was a british
politician
took his speech and kind of paraphrased
it as his own
and then the press got on him and then
he was charged also with taking part of
bobby kennedy's speeches
and biden says
not to worry he reassured his staff he
said we have nothing to fear but fear
itself
hello internet i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report it is june 9th 2022
and that was johnny carson back when
late night comedy was actually comedy
weird wild stuff i did not know that
that was my johnny carson impression for
those of you that are over 40. i think
you got it i missed that guy i missed
when late night comedy was funny except
for the number one show in late night
comedy which is the greg gutfeld program
he has obliterated the rest of those
clowns and why am i mentioning all of
this well because the elderly man
pretending to be president joseph r
biden
who johnny carson was making fun of
there that was by the way that was 1987.
joe biden had already been in government
for 58 years at that point
and yes he was a plagiarist back then
you may not know this but joe biden had
ran for president right around then
around 88 or so and had to end his
campaign because of this plagiarism
scandal so this guy's been doing it
forever he's been a fraud forever okay
fine now he just doesn't even know what
he's doing but he went on the jimmy
kimmel program last night and jimmy
kimmel of course you may remember him
from one of his many blackface scandals
he's a very unfunny guy gets paid about
20 million a year on abc to give you
just generic nonsense comedy comedy and
they went on and the interview was an
abject
disaster and of course it wasn't aired
live so they edit it and you really have
to understand this about television i'm
doing this thing live right now right so
like if clyde who's in studio by the way
with me right now and if you want to see
a picture of him you can go to
rubinreport.locals.com
in the live chat phoenix is putting a
picture of clyde in studio he's chilling
out with us because we've got some
construction workers down there but i'm
doing this thing live right now right so
whatever happens happens that's how it
is but this thing was pre-taped and it
was off the rails disastrous we've got a
couple clips of it that we're going to
show you and then because it is thursday
we are doing a locals community q a and
the questions are
varied and wide and all over the place
uh and also uh
we are doing a new thing as of last week
on thursdays in the locals community we
do thursday thoughts which is where you
guys just post whatever your thought of
the day is and we pick the most
interesting or insightful or funny or
comical or humorous or depressing or
whatever it might be thought and i uh
sign and date a little bit one of my
pages from my notes and uh we send it
off to you that's what we're doing every
thursday you can join us at
reubenport.logos.com real quick let me
talk to you about tommy john then we'll
get to joseph r biden the elderly man
pretending to be president and the
blackface man with the late night show
uh you know guys the best gift for your
dad is one he'd love but wouldn't get
for himself unbelievably comfortable
tommy john underwear tommy john moves
with you and keeps you cool thanks to
breathable lightweight fabric with four
times the stretch of competing brands
because tommy john knows that you're the
most confident when you're the most
comfortable that's why they don't have
customers they have fanatics with over
17 million pairs sold dads everywhere
love tommy john underwear look at that
guy he's loving it
they love it because it makes you feel
fresh all day long plus i'm going to be
a dad in a couple months and i do have
to make sure my underwear is right i
might as well start acting one now like
one now and you should get tommy john
too there's no risk because everything's
covered with tommy john's best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guaranteed
this father's day shop tommyjohn.com
reuben for up to thirty dollars off site
wide plus free shipping now through june
15th get up to thirty dollars off site
wide plus free shipping at tommyjohn.com
reuben
tommyjohn.com reuben and now back to me
all right so the elderly man pretending
to be president went on the blackface
late night tv show
to kind of clean up everything that's
going on in the country right now
because as you know we have a lot of
problems from gas prices to inflation to
supply chains to that sort of half war
we're doing and a whole bunch of other
stuff uh here's part one of what
happened and it ain't pretty
no question so there's a lot of major
things we've done
but what we haven't done is we haven't
been able to communicate it in a way
that is uh um
like might say another way well see
that's kind of perfect yeah well i've
been able to communicate but look how
the press has changed
look how the press is it has changed oh
listen i i get it i know you get you
overstand it you don't just understand
you overstand it
but here's the deal one of the things is
that it's very difficult now
to have a
um
even
with notable exceptions even the really
good reporters they have to get number
clicks on on on nightly news
so instead of asking a question
anyway it's just everything gets
gets sensationalized and weighs it but
i'm convinced we can get through this we
have to get through it and one of the
things look i'm going to take a break
and then we'll talk a little bit more if
you don't mind i'm sorry i'm sorry we
have some of those commercials we have
some biracial commercials we need
i mean it would be funny if it wasn't
depressing that guy is supposed to be
the leader of the free world he cannot
complete
a full sentence without losing his train
of thought or being completely muddled
and not know what he's saying and uh
jimmy kimmel does something there that's
actually pretty depressing for any of
you for any of you that have had a
parent or a grandparent or anyone you
know that has that sort of degenerative
mind disease whatever it might be if
it's alzheimer's or dementia or anything
else i had i had one grandmother that
had it for sure and one that had a
little bit towards the end and i spent a
lot of time going to geriatric doctors
with my grandmother
it's depressing it's deeply depressing
it's scary you can see this the fear in
their eyes because sometimes they
realize what's going on he knows what's
going on dr jill biden knows what's
going on everyone around him knows
what's going on he's obviously on
medication that they're hiding like they
cannot hide this much longer and one of
these days it's just going to burst
forth and suddenly everyone in
mainstream media will be covering it but
what kimmel's doing there is very much i
remember that feeling when i was with my
grandmother and she would be losing her
train of thought or couldn't get to the
end of the sentence or couldn't remember
a word whatever it might be you kind of
pick it up for them you pick it up for
them and help them get there because
it's sad and it's weird and it's scary
actually it's scary for them it's scary
for you what's going on here and twice
he had to do that there on top of the
fact that uh joe biden thinks that you
get clicks on the nightly news
television programs and he just doesn't
know what he's doing he doesn't know
what he's doing and he lies of course
about everything which at this point
it's like does he know he's lying or are
they just handing him something or he's
just saying crazy [ __ ] here's a lie
look
here's who we are
we have the fastest growing economy in
the world the world the world
no we don't
we don't we don't that's a lie a lie a
lie no matter how many times you will
repeat it uh my buddy patrick bet david
who knows uh quite a bit about the
economy and just before we started the
show i was on youtube looking at his 25
million dollar house in fort lauderdale
the guy's doing all right uh he's
predicting that they're going to
announce a recession uh somewhere
between july 1st and 15th but it does
seem like it is officially
on the way and we know this is all
happening again this is one of those
things where i don't have to read you
all the statistics on the on the markers
or about the economy because you can all
feel it but he just says that and jimmy
kimmel doesn't say anything back to like
back to him like uh no that doesn't seem
right because it's just like a pr move
right this is not a real talk show this
is not a place where they're there to
discuss ideas and where they're really
there to get into what's going on it's
just a pr move by the administration in
a very pre-packaged edited way to make
biden look as good as possible so think
about it they end up airing this thing
trust me there were 20 clips that we
could have showed you that are
absolutely disastrous they did this to
make joe biden look good because he
hasn't done a press conference and what
was it 120 days i think they told me
right before we started um so he won't
go up to the press straight up right he
won't take unsolicited questions he
won't do any of this stuff live anymore
so this is pre-packaged and it still
makes him look terrible here listen to
this rambling lunacy i'm serious you
turn on the tv look at the ads when's
the last time you saw biracial couples
on tv when's the last time you saw the
way i mean people are selling products
they do ads to sell products and they
sell products when people they appeal to
people this generation is going to
change everything we just got to make
sure we don't give up
what is he talking about what is he
talking about and nobody cares about
biracial couples on tv i'm not sure if
he's saying that there are biracial
couples on tv or there aren't or he
wants more i guess is what he's saying
nobody cares every time you open up a a
magazine or you watch television i don't
watch television anymore but i assume
that there's a lot of biracial couples
i'll tell you something funny you know
we're buying strollers right now because
we're having kids every freaking website
that's selling strollers or baby stuff
it's all lesbian couples and it's angry
lesbian couples michael you saw the
picture he was cracking up they have
these seemingly very angry lesbian
couples and they're out in the field
with the pushing the stroller and
they're very angry and
i'm a lesbian and i'm in the field with
the kid and it's like i have no problem
with lesbian parents but most people who
are parents are not lesbian or gay men
that's just how it is but everything is
being pushed through this pr drivel this
woke pr nonsense but what is he even
talking about nobody knows what he's
talking about
meanwhile matthew mcconaughey actor
matthew mcconaughey who i kind of like
he's over at the white house talking
about gun control now i'm not thrilled
with some of the things he's saying but
it's like he's basically acting as the
president while they send the elderly
man pretending to be president to go do
the silly uh
silly jimmy kimmel show here's one more
they tried to have joe biden do a
pre-packaged joke now note the
pre-packaged nature of this this is full
on if you want to just peel back and i
know a little something about hollywood
i'm pretty sure i'm never going to be
allowed back in
but if you want to just peel back a
little bit how they operate when these
guys do these talk shows they call it
panel it means you're going on the panel
you're the guy sitting next to the guy
at the desk and it's all pre-packaged
these are the questions you're going to
get here are the jokes you're going to
land there's stuff on the prompter so
you don't forget what you're going to do
the host obviously has notes and he has
a prompter the audience literally if
you've never been to one of these shows
the audience has a sign that lights up
when they're supposed to clap like seals
and when they're supposed to applaud
there are pas production assistants who
stand out in the crowd literally
encouraging you to laugh and and trying
to get you to go because none of it's
that funny it's all theater it's all
theater so watch this as they plan this
joke out
just so perfectly you'd often get asked
look the republicans don't play it
square why do you play square yeah well
well guess what if we do the same thing
they do our democracy will literally be
in jeopardy
well i mean i'm not a joke
and i i understand that argument but
also it's like you're playing monopoly
with somebody who you know won't pass go
and won't follow any of the rules and
how do you ever make any progress if
they're not
following the
rules to jail uh you know
you got to send them to jail so you can
see kimmel's reading off so he's reading
his pre-pan
pre-planned monopoly joke and then joe
biden obviously you got to send them to
jail and it's just like i don't even
care i'm not even going to say that joe
biden really wants to send his opponents
to jail
the people coming behind him do but i'm
not going to say joe biden's but it's
just like all of it it's so fake and
even the laughter there it feels fake
like the one guy that laughed and people
are like oh was that funny or is jailing
your opponents money it's all just
absolute drip full
all right we're going to get to the q a
real quick let me talk to you about
bullying max you know as inflation
surpasses highs don't tell joe biden not
seen in 40 years the value of the dollar
is decreasing with every passing day
you're paying more at the pump yes the
grocery store yeah for cor for cars and
housing it's true
face it your paper money is worth less
friends the timing couldn't be any
better for my new sponsor bullion max
bullion max is a direct to consumer
precious metals retailer who can help
you diversify into gold and silver it's
a hedge against inflation it's also
security for your family in times of
crisis and here's why i love bullying
max they're owned by veterans in the
precious metal space offers some of the
lowest prices on the internet and they
make it so easy to buy directly from
their website i want to help you get
started so i worked out a special offer
just for you
get bullion max's silver starter kit at
employee pricing just go to
bullionmax.com dave the kit includes
five of the most desirable silver
products to invest in including a silver
american eagle and a silver australian
kangaroo the offer is limited to just
one per household so get yours now go to
bullionmax.com dave right now and now
back to me
or trust joe biden on the economy it's
up to you people okay here we go
reubenreport.locals.com community q a
patrick
says uh dave do you believe as i do that
the democrats have become so depraved
that they actually hope a supreme court
justice is bumped off so that biden can
tip the balance with a new endpoint
appointee of course of course they
fundamentally believe the uh ends
justify the means okay
so whatever you have to do to get to the
end result you want is okay that's why
nobody in the mainstream media is trying
to figure out who did the leak right
this big roe v wade leak the supreme
court leak this is a massive breach of
protocol of how the supreme court is
supposed to operate that each one of the
justices has i think four clerks there's
a couple people around them but there's
a very limited amount of people who have
access to these briefs someone and i
assume there is some level of an
investigation uh should be trying to
figure out who leaked this because it's
an affront and an assault on the supreme
court but you didn't see anyone in the
media really right did anyone in the
mainstream media really run around and
say hey we got to figure this thing out
and we have to figure out who did this
and why they did it and how it happened
so there is almost nothing there is no
norm i mean i think that's really the
way we have to look at this thing if you
just look at like the train right and
the train's just going
and it's just going and going going and
there's some signals every now and again
you know the thing's coming down you got
to stop you got to slow down there is
nothing they will not ram through just
yesterday an armed man was arrested
outside brett kavanaugh's house well if
you run around and tell people for years
that brett kavanaugh is a serial rapist
and he was installed by a racist and the
process is illegitimate and all of those
things then people are going to start
doing weird things and then when you
take some of the video that we've shown
you over the months where democrats are
the ones get in their face give them no
peace it's okay to protest at people's
house houses would they love if one of
them just dropped dead yeah by the way i
can do a version of that that's not
completely partisan are there a certain
amount of people on the right that would
be happy if a liberal judge just croaked
if it was a conservative president of
course but i don't think the bloodlust
the general bloodlust and disregard for
the norms of the court is the same on
the right because generally people on
the right think that the country is good
think that the system is good it doesn't
mean that there's no partisanship but
the basic belief is oh the system has to
kind of work itself out
so it is what it is the guy who drove
over to kavanaugh's house is saying that
he had the intention to kill him i mean
that's the level of kind of where we're
at at the moment
lawrence says i don't think you
addressed this how did you fare in the
first tropical storm in florida uh some
flooding images were very serious yeah
so there was a couple massive storms
here in miami the last couple days so
we're not right in downtown i'm more in
the suburbs so if you saw the videos
from downtown we should have we should
have played a couple on b-roll i mean
they were crazy like 2-3 foot middle of
the city of brickell which is downtown
miami like people coming out of clubs
and like being swept away i don't think
there were any deaths or anything but
massive massive flooding there was a
bunch of flooding by us nothing too
terrible
last night though we did have some crazy
storms and we had just done we're doing
a bunch of landscaping right now so
we're moving trees around and obviously
when you move trees and you plant trees
it takes a little while for the roots to
get settled so we have two trees that
toppled over did you guys see the two
trees toppled over in the front we have
two trees that fell over but we're
working on it i got jose here he's
helping me out he's a good dude shout
out to jose and uh yeah it's okay we
haven't had any power outages or
anything we're working on the generator
situation and by and large uh if if
that's as bad as it gets in this free
state i am quite happy
chris says do you see the red wave
coming if so is there a downside
to it yeah i mean look as i've been
saying every every marker would show you
that there's a red wave coming right
even if you took out every bad thing
that's happening right now usually in
midterm elections if you have a democrat
president republicans with the midterm
if you have a republican president the
democrats win the midterm meaning it's
the off party that usually does well
right um
but if you add all of the bad stuff
that's happening then yes there is every
reason to think there's going to be a
red wave but you just don't know
right you just don't know what these
freaking people are gonna do what will
the machine do what will the corporate
press do you know even as we speak right
now what are they really trying to get
people focused on i know you're not
focused on it and i couldn't give a
flying uh there'll be nice clydes here i
couldn't give a flying bird about it
either uh the january 6th thing it's
like it's so irrelevant it's a complete
sideshow but they want you to be focused
on the wrong things so you can't even
see what's right in front of you which
are food prices and gas prices and
everything else
so it's like
we can't get overconfident you've got to
vote and you've got to encourage your
friends to vote and get out there and
remain active and not just vote get on
school boards and all of the other stuff
because not all of these uh problems
will be solved purely in a political
sense they can be solved by you being
more active in your community at the
schools and all that kind of stuff
but look it's like kovid could come come
back you know two weeks before the
election now we got to do mail-in
ballots everywhere that could happen
they could ramp up a war like anything
could happen
but man cross your fingers cross your
fingers but don't but don't just do it
with like hope you got to cross your
fingers and say i'm going to do
something and it's like
we got a chance to just set this thing
right i mean imagine if the republicans
took the congress which i think is
likely there's a chance they'll take the
senate right you completely neuter biden
right and then he's just neutered and
he's mentally neutered already but now
the administration is neutered for two
years and then actually if the
republicans started doing some things
legislatively right or they kicked some
of the power back to the state or they
made sure we're not going to go into
lockdowns again or any of those things
like if they started doing that stuff
then we got a great chance to hey get a
maybe a ron desantis guy in 2024 or
something else like we shall see
sierra says now that you're settled in
miami which fruits and vegetables are
you planning on growing so the only
thing that we're growing at the moment
i've got some awesome tomato plants
going right now because we just had
perfect little planters that were ready
to roll and i've got
some nice ways that they're kind of
growing up the wall and it's really cool
although it is in the summer in florida
it's very hard to grow tomatoes as i've
been told by several people you got to
keep trimming them because you need as
much air to go through of them because
obviously it's very hot and humid here
but they're actually doing pretty well
and i've got some nice sweet juicy
tomatoes
in the kitchen right now that's the only
thing we're growing right now i'm going
to build out some planters because i
want to do a full a full-on garden it's
been tough because of all the all the
rain right now and then we are going to
put in a couple uh fruit trees we do
have a mango tree
which was really old on the property
which we just fed and hopefully it'll
come around and then we found out
literally a week ago we've had this
massive massive
probably 40 year old tree in the corner
of the property and it wasn't looking so
great and we went back there i went with
my landscaper and i was like what's
going on with this thing you know and
he's like you know this is a avocado
tree and we looked around and there were
some avocados but the tree had just been
overgrown and not fed and everything so
we just shaped it up we fed it it's
looking good and hopefully we will have
uh we'll have some avocados oh yeah and
we have a banana tree so we've got
plenty of bananas around here some of
you that follow on locals may have seen
the bananas which will be very
very useful in case of monkey pox
because i have been told and you know
i'm not a scientist i'm not you know
somebody that works over at the cdc you
know don't you know i'm not as qualified
as fouchy but somebody said the best way
to keep monkey pox uh away from you and
keep you and your family safe is to eat
17 bananas a day that's what i was told
so we have tremendous amount of bananas
here you guys can all bananas after the
show
derek says will we ever see another
episode of you jordan and ben again i
love it when you three have a
conversation if i'm not mistaken that
two or three hour conversation was the
longest ever episode of the reuben
report and it was a very special day for
me not only because it was so cool to
you know sort of the height of the idw
thing and it was cool to be with those
two guys as all of the stuff was kind of
blowing up
but when jordan walked out
of the
studio which was in my garage he was
doing his first ever live show that
night it was a test show he hadn't the
book wasn't out he hadn't decided
whether he was going to tour or anything
like that he was going to do the orpheum
downtown la couple thousands
couple thousand seat theater and i said
to him kind of as a joke i was like hey
if you want me to come and make some
jokes about lobsters tonight and warm up
the crowd for you let me know but i was
kind of joking about it i didn't really
think he was gonna say yes like this was
a big event for him uh and he was like
he was like yeah come on down and i did
it and the agents were there and i
crushed it and they were like you want
we're going to take this thing on tour
this has been awesome you want to do it
and my life changed so that was a that
was a really great day for me uh glenn
says could you oh so wait sorry i didn't
ask answer your question so the question
is will we ever do it again well i just
had dinner with jordan last week jordan
and i are going to do a sit down live
here in miami sometime in july ben also
is in florida so i think we're going to
do a solo one and i'll see if we can get
mr shapiro to be involved in something
else see what we can pull off all right
what does ben say
what does glenn say phoenix you gotta
scroll a little faster thank you
could you be friends with someone that
you agree with on almost every common
issue
but that person has an unbending stance
against gay marriage good question all
right so
well well first off on the first part of
the question i would i don't certainly
don't have to agree with them on almost
every issue i i like having friends that
i disagree with on a lot of issues
obviously as things have gotten
politically charged in this country you
guys all know this it's getting harder
and harder to do
generally speaking it's not harder to do
because of us right like i'm okay with
someone disagreeing with me on abortion
i'm okay with someone disagreeing with
me on taxes and foreign policy and all
of those things uh i'm okay with someone
even disagreeing me disagreeing with me
on my feelings about the woke nonsense
but the other side seems to be unable to
have friends that disagree with them
like it's conformity is what they seem
to put at the highest level of the
hierarchy they pretend it's tolerance
but it's really conformity um but you're
asking an interesting one so
uh if someone had an unbending stance
against gay marriage well i think
there's there's sort of two parts of
this one part is i believe that anyone's
entitled to their own beliefs and their
own religious
liberty and thoughts so could i be
friends with someone who had a biblical
view of what marriage is well absolutely
i could be i think it would sort of cap
the friendship at a certain level so
since we were just talking about ben
shapiro i would i would include him in
something like this ben and i absolutely
are friends we have had dinner mentor
many times we obviously are allies in a
political sense uh but he has a biblical
view of marriage now
that does cap our friendship to a
certain degree right like it it just
does like there's a level of something
there that we're never going to get to
that's okay i don't feel i need to own
the world i don't think he feels he
needs to own the world as far as i know
he mostly takes the libertarian position
of the government should just stay out
of it and people should be able to enter
whatever contracts they want but there
would be a cap
on it there now the difference would be
so i can be friends with someone in that
regard the difference would be if there
was someone that was like actively
constantly campaigning to overturn gay
marriage or to make sure that gay people
didn't have equal rights or something
like that well then i probably would
have
a tough time being friends with them but
if you just had your own sort of
philosophical view of the world but you
were a nice person and a decent person
and an interesting person and a
thoughtful person and all of that stuff
then i then i think i would be fine with
it i know i would be fine with it uh
danielle says lots of good documentaries
are recently out and upcoming if you
were going to make a documentary what
would be the topic what would you want
to expose it's a good question because
i've had a few documentary companies
want to do things with me or things that
i would narrate or that i would sort of
walk through
be the sort of lead to do you know it
would obviously be mostly about the
mainstream media i i think things are so
much worse than we really realize i mean
actually what we started with today the
joe biden on jimmy kimmel like how the
machine operates you know jimmy kimmel
who spent four years lying and
slandering and awful jokes about trump
and he's a racist and all that stuff
jimmy kimmel who of course has been in
blackface multiple times himself
donald trump as far as i know has never
been in blackface he's been an orange
face quite a lot but that's a different
thing
um how the machine
protects itself so it's like you lie
about the person you don't like and then
you do this ridiculously edited softball
interview with the guy that you do like
you're literally literally defending him
and and lying and obfuscating for him
as he's losing his thought twice in
three sentences as we just showed you he
did not know what he was saying it was
going nowhere you can see all of the
cognitive little tricks that he's
learned so he doesn't completely just
dump out like break down error
right in front of us right and jimmy
kimmel helps him get and now we got to
go to commercial oh that's a really
great point like it's all fake
everything about the mainstream media is
fake everything is deeply deeply fake
and
i would like to explore that a little
bit more i mean i know you guys get it
but i think there's like another level
another layer of that onion that we
could peel off that would be pretty good
so i will have to think about that are
you guys busy enough you want to do a
documentary what do you think you guys
busy we'll see
guys before we get to a couple more
questions let me talk to you about real
estate agents i trust you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment that's a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents
their team makes the intro and then
follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied their agents work with people
with long track records they all have
long track records and they're the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience the company's owned by my
buddy glenn beck they share your values
and they're almost anywhere you want to
go including miami florida the process
is simple just go to real estate agents
itrust.com today and provide them with
some basic info their team will contact
you to make an introduction to their
preferred agent in your town and then
you see what happens all right let's
move on carob says i loved meeting you
at the breakfast in orlando i went solo
that day but really enjoyed meeting you
all it was like we were old friends when
we will have updates to locals like
direct message many of us have become
close friends here we'd love to
communicate directly without using email
or other means well it was great to meet
you it was great to meet we had about a
hundred people for breakfast i took
everybody out for breakfast it was just
great see all these happy people
and you guys have become friends as you
as you rightly point out that which is
so cool right like that's just so cool
people that live in the same town or
live across the country people are
actually becoming friends with each
other in real life like if i've done
anything good here i suppose that's
probably it uh your question about some
updates on locals when will we have
things like direct message that would be
ways for you guys to message each other
we're working on it so we really want to
expand the offering so right now you
know when we started this thing it was
the idea
that the creator could just get their
stuff out to you guys you guys could
comment on it post things things like
that but we are realizing there's a much
more robust uh set of features that we
should be putting together and we're
working on a few of them so we want you
guys basically to have a messenger where
you can communicate not only with me but
with each other which of course we'll do
uh totally encrypted uh we want there to
be profile pages for you guys so we can
sort of rethink the internet you know
basically i want to create something
where everyone can just cancel their
facebook page cancel all the stuff that
you've got and then have a loca you
would have your own locals page and this
is the idea that we're going for you
would have your own locals page where
you can put your videos and your audios
and you can find other people's pages to
comment on really just kind of scale it
back as if almost in some ways as if we
could go back 20 years ago when everyone
got on facebook but we knew about all
the stuff like what would we have
cleaned up or what would facebook what
should facebook have cleaned up if we
did it more maturely uh so yes we'll
have messenger we'll have profile pages
we'll you know it'll be a storage bin
for your stuff um and some other tricks
that they probably would not want me to
tell you so stay tuned for all of that
uh jacob says love the show since you
are a gay conservative very scary what
are your thoughts on pride month and
everything about becoming rainbow
well first off um you know
i happen to be gay and i suppose at this
point i'm a conservative i don't find
those things to be that in conflict i
know a certain amount of people do
you guys don't i know my audience does
and i know there's some people that do
uh but to me well gay is just the
sexuality zippity doodah and
conservative you know conservative
basically as i joke during a lot of the
live shows it's like conservative
basically means you know you've got a
job you know conservative basically
means you wear your underwear inside
your pants conservative basically means
you believe in some
truths that we know are true and not
everything is up for debate and then we
can all have sort of our own religious
beliefs or philosophical or secular
beliefs around all that conservative
basically means you think the united
states is pretty good you believe in the
rule of law uh things of that nature you
believe in logic and reason um but
are as far as my thoughts on pride month
and everything because i mean first off
you know pride is not something you need
a month for pride isn't even something
you need a day for pride isn't something
you have to scream about like i am proud
of what i do the work that i do
what i've presented to the world i
suppose um i wasn't always proud of
everything that i've done i'm not proud
of everything i've done in my past you
know what i mean but that first off the
idea that it's a month is just
completely ridiculous that we have a
month a black history month and a pride
none of it means anything it's just it's
all corporate package nonsense um but
there's something specific about the
word pride that i don't like it's like
pride isn't something you have to tell
people you have like pride is something
you earn by doing something good by
living a good life you will feel pride
in what you do so i want nothing to do
with it i have nothing to do with it it
has nothing to do with me they've also
ruined the rainbow you know the rainbow
used to be fun the rainbow was a couple
colors and went like this and at the
other end you might find a pot of gold
with a [ __ ] pretty good
everybody likes that
oh wait [ __ ] gets us demonetized i
always forget is that
no no no no no come on
[Laughter]
that would be pretty good i don't think
[ __ ] gets us demonetized that would be
insane midgets are people too right okay
media matters is all over that one
ruben says midgets are people too are
they
um
the point is people uh i just they
ruined the rainbow like they took the
rainbow then they slapped all of these
brown things on it and these pink things
and all of these things this there's no
such thing as the lgbt community none of
it means anything i have a community of
people around me but it's not because oh
you are into this and you're into that
and you used to be a chick and now
you're a dude and all of those things
it's just like no none of it means
anything i like individual people i
think george carlin had a line on that
it's something like i like individual
people groups not so much
tony says have you considered an
interview with russell brand he seems to
be making a lot of sense these days and
it looks like he has a local community
he is on locals he is on rumble and he
is making a lot of sense he's saying a
lot of the stuff that i've been saying
for a while which does you know it's a
little bit of a pat on the back i
suppose to me uh i have not connected
with him yet um but we do have some
mutual friends i'm sure we will at some
point i would love to sit down with him
either
on his show on my show on both shows
doesn't have to even be in public uh
just a private meeting just have a drink
and see what's what uh but he is getting
red pilled pretty quickly he was a you
know this was guy that was basically a
leftist hollywood leftist five years ago
uh he had an interview with candace
owens a couple years ago where she
really smacked him around a little bit
and he took the hit you know sort of
took the hit the way i took the hit with
that original larry elder interview so
anyone that's trying to figure out
what's going on here anyone who's
thinking a little bit differently doing
things a little bit differently i'm
interested in that so i would be happy
to talk to him philip says how's the
knee holding up especially with all the
recent traveling the knees in good shape
man i better knock on wood
you know i got this torn acl and all
right i know i should get the surgery my
guy wants me to get it but i did prp
platelet-rich plasma they suck your
blood out they spin it in the centrifuge
they inject the plasma back into you it
will not repair a torn acl but it sort
of strengthens everything around that my
knee is good i'm doing cardio every day
i'm trying to
lift again a little bit and i got
something going on my shoulder
age
sucks
but i'm feeling pretty good i'm playing
when it's not raining i've been i've
been shooting hoops again i got the spin
move back it's so it's it's all there
thanks for asking
wayne says do you think elon will back
out of the twitter deal if he finds that
they've been cooking the books yes
absolutely and i'm starting to think
that's where this is all gonna go
and maybe he knew that the entire time
wouldn't that be something that elon had
done his due diligence probably for
months like this is not the type of guy
who's just like hey hey i'm gonna throw
44 billion dollars at something without
doing my homework right so what if he
had done a whole bunch of research
beforehand all
that month-long pr and is it going to
happen isn't it going to happen does he
have the money will the board stop it
all of the stuff happens
but then as they're doing discovery
right because when you buy a company
obviously you can't just trust them that
the books make sense you got to go in
and start looking you got to look at
what they've done how many fake accounts
are here does the accounting really
match are they really generating revenue
on these things are they faking numbers
are they depressing views are they
shadow banning all of the stuff so what
if he knew a whole bunch about it and he
knew the only way he could really expose
it was to say he's gonna buy it knowing
that the sale never would have to go
through
because it was all going to come out
that the whole thing was fraudulent so
if i'm not mistaken in the in the
original deal there was a sort of a
clause in there that basically said oh
about five percent of the accounts are
bots meaning these are fake accounts
that are computer run you know they
could come from foreign countries or
they could come from domestic people or
just trolls or whatever it is but about
five percent are fake and and he
wrote the 44 million billion offer under
the guise of 5
now it's looking like it could be 20
some people are saying it could be like
40 50 of fake accounts now think about
the ways we could be being manipulated
if politicians who tweet things if 40 of
the people who retweet them or encourage
them to say one thing or get their
uh base going behind them because they
see a lot of likes on one thing if it's
fake energy right if it's fake that's
something that's something real so maybe
elon knew it he wasn't happy about it
and he knew the only way he could expose
it was to say he was going to buy the
thing i have no insight or knowledge on
that i don't know that's the case um but
if he finds out it's more than five
percent fake he probably should not buy
it and honestly if he didn't buy it and
he really exposed the whole thing like i
would gladly get off twitter i want to
get off twitter anyway i i said it when
knowles interviewed me a couple weeks
back i would love to be off twitter by
the end of the year that would really be
great look we're building locals where
i'm having way more fun that's where i
inter
i interact with people and now i'm
meeting people in real life i don't
interact with people on twitter i just
put information out there and that's
where i get information so i we haven't
built that whole infrastructure yet
but
maybe the whole thing needs to just
collapse maybe it's so deeply corrupt
what they did by hiding the hunter biden
story by getting rid of trump by all the
shadow banning by all the fake accounts
again it's like if we were all playing
if we were all playing a sport or we
were all playing a board game and we
knew it was kind of fixed so that one
guy was going to win all the time or one
guy's rules were different than the
other guy's rules one team was allowed
to you know travel but the other team
couldn't right um you might go boy this
game isn't that fun anymore you know the
harlem globetrotters always won all the
time maybe there was a reason they won
all the time right like the generals
didn't do that well remember didn't the
generals win one game i think they
accidentally won one game if i'm not
mistaken
um
so the point is we're all playing this
fixed game but it's like until we really
figure out what's better or what the
alternatives are i think we're all going
to keep playing it but we're working on
it uh curtis says if governor desantis
becomes president
and he asks you to join his team what
position do you think he would appoint
you to
wow well i think anything's possible as
far as desantis for the record i did not
ask him on stage about whether he wants
to run for president i didn't feel it
was really appropriate or necessary i
think there's far more things to deal
with in florida right now the guy
freaking loves this state and he wants
to crush it in his re-election and go
from there
i'm hearing some grumblings i heard
yesterday that
the orange man may announce as early as
july there's a rumor it's going to
happen on july 4th we'll see about that
which it's like people keep asking me
what i think and it's like
look
biden and this whole
machine they've got us on the slow
descent to hell and we all feel it we
all know it trump getting back in it
just opens the gates of hell right so
it's either the slow descent to hell or
the open the gates hell now the the
positive part of that is if you open the
gates to hell maybe all the [ __ ] just
comes flying out and then we can do a
reset and i think we were sort of
heading there until they kneecapped him
last time with the 18 impeachments and
everything else so i don't know exactly
what's going to happen there i do hope
that whatever happens that trump and
desantis are able to
kind of come together and figure out a
way to to fight together whether it's
one of them running and the other one
defending or the other way around
but as for your question directly what
position do i think he would appoint me
to if he was to appoint me i mean press
secretary would be the most obvious like
i could do what sake does and i would do
it far better it would be fun and funny
and the media would be evil and i'd
probably get fired in three days because
i'd say something that i wasn't supposed
to say or whatever although i don't
think desantis would fire me he'd like
it but it would be a lot of controversy
but you know he's got an awesome press
secretary right now christina pusha who
by the way in the last couple days this
girl has been under an onslaught of
attacks from the floridian mainstream
media where they're calling her a
registered foreign agent and all this
[ __ ] and and desantis had a great
line on it they asked him because
there's all these media reports that
christina pusha that she's evil and
she's bad and she's a foreign agent and
she's desantis press secretary so they
asked desantis about it it was just
perfect he was like he was like let me
get this straight the mainstream media
is going after my press secretary that
means she's doing a good job and it's
just it's just like that's the right
answer that's perfect so she would
probably do that i could be in charge of
smoking meat that would be good i could
bring the
big green egg to the white house and do
what i could over there uh maybe i could
replace gay pete
you know
i probably would know more about
transportation that wasn't even a gay
joke i i've uh i used to play uh what
was that simcity remember simcity you
build roads around and the whole thing
so i feel like i could do what gay pete
does uh nick says even as an outspoken
college student fighting the good fight
good for you nick meeting you and the
locals community last week gave me a new
inner strength i didn't know i needed
awesome did you ever imagine that you'd
be able to touch so many souls
i'm going to cry um
i don't know i don't know that i ever
really thought about it but i can tell
you that when we did that breakfast and
when i do the meet and greets after and
people say you help you help keep me
sane and people giving us baby gifts and
people are giving me tequila and people
are giving me candles and people are
giving me hand paintings and
there was a guy i wish i could remember
his name who gave me two painted animals
from his i think four-year-old autistic
son and they're awesome
and we're gonna hang them in the house
when we're done with all this
construction it's like that i have some
little effect on whatever's going on
with your life that maybe i've made some
of like the craziness of these last
couple years a little more palatable for
you
is awesome and um
it's it's like
if that's what i'm giving you guys then
you're giving me back way more right
like you've afforded me literally and
figuratively like a really good life and
that is very appreciated uh appreciate
it on my end so uh yeah thank you
uh renee
says on a scale from one to a hundred
what was california and what is florida
i mean california well i gotta put some
money in the jar here we're gonna put
ten in today we're going to put 10 in
today there you go cali someone's
getting some cash
um
what was california and what was florida
i mean california look when i got there
in 2013 we got there in 2013. we had
about 2 000 bucks in our
combined bank accounts and when we left
you know eight years later like we had
made it you go to hollywood to make it
and and we did it right 99 of people go
and don't make it like it never works
out they they never get whatever the
dream was i don't even remember exactly
what my dream was but i do have a note
we have this somewhere we're going to
frame it we still have boxes we haven't
fully unpacked but we have a piece of
paper that david and i wrote from about
2012 where i was formulating the idea of
a show called the reuben report from way
back when um and and it was really
originally an idea i had back in 2005
when i was doing stand-up from before
but the point is we went to cali and we
we did what you're supposed to do like i
built a company i did
i have the job i want to have and all of
that stuff
cali was great for a while like southern
california when it's right man the
weather is awesome
and you know there was something cool
about the celebrity thing being a little
bit involved in that kind of thing like
there is something kind of cool about it
when it's done right can you hear clyde
he's he's scratching how you doing clyde
what's going on you want to get out here
we can let him out somebody let him out
of here before he pees in the studio um
but there was something awesome about
cali and it really was the weather and
the beaches and all that stuff and i
loved going up to northern cali we got
married in wine country
and like there was something really cool
about all that oh now he doesn't want to
leave this guy all right now you're
staying dude um
anyway here i'll take a picture of him
now we'll post this in a second clyde
we're taking a live picture of you
during the show
for the people we'll post this in local
clyde look at me look at me how you
doing how you doing okay
um
so there was something really cool about
cali so and then and then of course it
was a disaster then it went off the
cliff right like it's just the coat the
lockdowns covered the destruction of
everything the homeless all the stuff
you know so cali i'd give it a 50 i'd
give it a 50 out of 100. it was good and
then it and then it turned to [ __ ]
florida it's a 98
it's a 98. i don't know anything bad
here in florida do you guys know
oh clyde's freaking out he's we got
people banging downstairs um
i don't know anything bad that's going
on here the weather is great the the
people are great there's a happiness
here a yearning for freedom i've become
friendly with the mayor of miami and and
the governor where i was an enemy of the
state and it has and it's not even the
political stuff like nothing i love the
lizards like i really like reptiles i
think that's one of the things that i've
learned here reptiles i like lizards i
like iguanas i like alligators i like
crocodiles name another iguana a reptile
for me what do we got i named the i like
snakes there i said it i don't mind the
snakes
all right big show today guys i hope you
enjoyed the q a we've got a cold close
for you in a second that i think you are
going to dig reminder speaking of
florida and miami i am going to be in
miami we added one last show for my new
adopted hometown of miami
july 14th at the miami improv you can
get tickets at daverubin.com
events look at those cool hipster synth
wave sunglasses part two of my interview
with governor ron desantis is on rumble
and uh youtube right now the full thing
is up at room.locals.com
and now we got a cold clothes for you
these are the people pretending to be in
charge
we did it we did it joe
you're going to be the next president of
the united states
by the way it's my little sister valerie
and i'm jill's husband oh no a guy oh
you switched on me this my wife is my
sister they switched on me